How can we check if all the images
on a site have been optimized?
Remember that in order to serve
the smallest possible image file on your
site, you need to make sure you've run
images through optimization tools.
Now, one great tool for
checking this is PageSpeed Insights.
Let's use that to check
a page from our website.
One image that needs some help.
We can also use PageSpeed Insights
from the dev tools.
Just click Analyze.
Best of all, there's
a PageSpeed Insights API that let's you
incorporate checking
within your workflow.
Here I'm running a code command to
make an HTTP request from a terminal.
Key here holds the value of my
API key for PageSpeed Insights.
And I'm redirecting the response
of that request to psi.jason.
Let's open up that file and
take a look at the output.
Looks like psi found one image
that needs to be optimized,
same as it did from the website.
You could easily incorporate this
into build tests when pushing code to
a repository, for example using
a task runner such as grunt.
In fact there's even a grunt plug-in for
PageSpeed Insights.
For more information about using
PageSpeed to check images with grunt
take a look at the link below the video.